hey guys one of the great things about
the LAV is that the rocks around a whole
lot and some things are obviously gonna
be for show but sometimes things come
along they can stand alone and what
you're about to watch is something that
I know will bring value to so so many of
you it's a long clip but it's advice
that 65% of my audience really needs and
and I hope you enjoy it how old are you
perfect you're at the point now where
why don't you just take three years and
just do and see what that tastes like
cuz you know what [ __ ] feeling
Journal's tastes like because I think
one of the things that really works for
me is I'm not worried about the micro
but I think about the macro oh I don't
know where the [ __ ] this just came from
but I just walked in and saw it this
helps me a lot like like I just like
what the [ __ ] am I doing with you right
now there's a lot more to do with the
[ __ ] showing up to the funeral than
it has to do with [ __ ] the bank
account and you know what's funny is
yeah if you actually live your life like
the funeral you end up making stuff for
the bank account by accident you end up
meeting somebody who you know like it's
so crazy when I think about like how I
invested in Twitter and made all that
money it was more about giving [ __ ]
about my funeral like doing the right
thing by a bunch of people which you
know led to go into South by Southwest
which led to me meeting the Twitter guys
which meant you know like it's just yeah
we've just got to really think about
like how like I'll tell you like even in
four seconds maybe some of the context
Robert gave me may be making some
assumptions but when you're thoughtful
like I think one of the things that
people feel like struggle with is
actually being very real with themselves
the difference between being you know
the difference between understanding who
you are versus who you wish you were and
I think that's something that I'm always
very fascinated by when I have a meeting
like this like what kind of read do you
have on yourself and how like you know I
think I would struggle a lot if I didn't
really genuinely know who I was and it
and then once you know who you are you
get more comfortable with what you're up
to
so like if I asked you right now and I
think it ebbs and flows when you're 28
one day 32 when you're 57 like I've
asked you right this second like
what do you want to happen and like
would you say what would happen with
like my creative projects or just with
my for a long way sure all of it all
right I wouldn't want to happen I yeah I
would have a life where I'm able to
create with fun create with the team I
want to put out content that affects
people's lives for the better in terms
of helping them feel good or better
about themselves and their relationships
and cultivating relationships are
meaningful I want to really like travel
with my man and like have property
international property and I travel for
fun or also for play and also a little
bit of time for work but controlling it
wouldn't bring like with ease and also
impact me for the better your process
cool no what are you hoping as you're
like rolling up to this office what are
you like what are you hoping for you
know what for real by the way yeah
furro furro I mean there are you know
[ __ ] that I do not know so I honestly
just want you to pick your brain about a
couple of key things and I really like
ideally like what I was hoping and what
I expected like to get in the place for
like I know you and I could hit me up
you had a meeting you start building
start the process of building a
relationship right okay let's start with
this if you want to like listening to
what you said the first thing I will
tell you the best thing I think I hope I
think the first best thing I can tell
you is don't front the number one
mistake that people that aspire to the
sentences that you just spit out of your
mouth the number one mistake they make
is they try to over sell themselves
because they think they need it to have
people's attention correct so let me
give an example
whether it's life coach inspirational
figure business coach whatever form it
takes I think it's much smarter for you
to talk to the world about your process
of going through
this than the advice that you shake
think you should be giving them yeah and
that's where people are struggling I I
got real lucky I've never said this
dirac so pay real close [ __ ]
attention I'm not sure that if the
internet was around in its current form
that I would be as successful because at
22 and 23 I knew I was special and I
might have not been patient enough to
first build a business first get
experience I didn't start talking to the
world so I was 35 hmm and I love to say
to you be patient to you to be patient
I'm not sure if I would have been I'd
like to think I would have been but the
freedom of putting like I love to hear
myself talk like like that guy you know
and I think anybody that a spot like to
think about so do you and so do so many
of you like that's what it is and it's
nice there's nothing wrong with that it
sounds bad
it's funny a lot of what I deal with now
is being okay with not being politically
correct work-life balance
cursing whatever let meritocracy you
know I don't know if you've seen this
did you see that I was on The Breakfast
Club so I don't know if you watch that
interview or some of the content that
I've been building on I'm on a hot no
excuses kick I have a lot of female
entrepreneurs I have a lot of fans that
are African Americans I spent a lot of
time in that community my college years
I just think I'm giving the best advice
to women and minorities in business
today which is tough and it's crazy like
you have to understand in my body right
now it doesn't feel great it feels a lot
better going somewhere else the problem
is it's the truth like the market just
doesn't care and what's cool is when you
actually say [ __ ] it then you start
betting on your strengths do you know I
was a businessman in a world where going
to smart colleges was the only thing
that mattered for businessmen you're
only a good businessman if you went to
Harvard Business School and then I
reversed it like I'm like I'm a DNF
student
like like I curse I don't dress the part
I do me and then you know what happened
the world came to me and so I would tell
you that the best thing that you're
gonna walk out of here with is something
that took me a long time to really
realize is if you want to pull this off
and you want people listening to you
there's only one thing the truth was the
[ __ ] and nope everybody says that
[ __ ] cliche term just be yourself no
that's it
it's unbelievable how much that's the
reason I'm winning hmm
and I think it's easier when you have a
level of success and it's harder when
you're climbing up the ladder but I
think that there's a lot of people who
if they talked about the journey of the
climb could win I think it's the best
piece of advice I can give right now to
a bunch of twenty to thirty year olds I
feel that they should be talking to the
world and bringing value talk about your
journey of trying to find that voice and
synthesize it properly versus let me
tell go fine you know because the
problem is a 30 40 50 year old listening
to your one-minute rant video on
Instagram even if it's powerful there's
a level of cynicism of like what do you
know yeah and I think that that's fair
and look you could just be a whiz kid
about the world and that exists but I do
think there's a smarter way to context
it you know it's like starting the
sentence of you should versus you know
it's funny right now I can say you
should because I built so much [ __ ] but
if I was at 20 it need to be like my
intuition says and I changes everything
or when I look at or when I met with
Gary today the takeaway I got was that's
got it yeah
what your perspective is on cultivating
relationships with people who not only
believe in your ideas can actually help
fund or will point you to functions
right now all my friends are broke and
trying to create some [ __ ] you know it's
like okay I can't borrow from your
negative bank account so how do you get
into a position where you are around
people who are influences or who also
will donate or whatever the case can be
the market will give you much the market
will give you money whether it's
Kickstarter I'll give you money you just
have to give somebody what you want it
against so the biggest problem right now
is finding money's not the problem
really it's not I'll explain
well I'm explain it's not it's how
you're looking at the world there's
things like angellist
and kicks do you know which harder was
for your mother to get money oh yeah
yeah I remember that's it like it like
that like do you know how hard somebody
would slap you that do you know that the
1973 version of you if he was sitting
here would punch you in your [ __ ]
mouth because money is the last thing
you have to worry about angellist
kickstarter the world can give it to you
you start a Kickstarter can you know why
most of them fail cuz most [ __ ] is whack
because most stuff isn't good because
most people don't give a [ __ ] you can go
to AngelList and hit up all the angel
investors the real question is before
you go there is I think most people say
everybody says to me Gary can't buy
money and then I go cool I'll give you
money what do you got and then I don't
know so tell me what am i what am i
buying your brand what in perpetuity got
it there's a we're living through a
really interesting time in the world
right now where people don't like where
art and science and business are
colliding and they're all very different
I understand the art that's in your
heart but how you gonna yeah see I got
lucky I had the art and the business but
like okay what am i buying there's no
bike look buying into Gary Vaynerchuk
would have been a really good idea for a
lot of people it wasn't for sale and I
even know how to sell that like what do
you sell like what are gonna make twenty
percent of my speaking fees
or my book deal or my TV deal are just
like right I guess you can do that
actually you think that plays out over
time but if I said to you cool I got
money for you what do you selling me
like what's the business what I hear
that is when you show up with more
content that allows people to see more
of what they're investing in no what I
would say is what's the container I'm
putting my money in you could have
unlimited country you could have 4,000
episodes of a podcast and the greatest
Instagram account I've ever seen and the
funniest snapchat Instagram stories I've
ever seen great so that's not inherently
letting people know what they recipe it
that lets them know a little bit about
you but what's the vessel got it please
so when I mean [ __ ] Jerry or would I
meet the fat Jewish I know they've got
attention on Instagram three years ago
that really matters what am i investing
in Oh Oh fat Jewish you're making a
rose' oh I can put $25,000 into that and
on 8% now you've given me something to
put the container in oh [ __ ] Jerry you
want to become BuzzFeed you're gonna
build a website and have traffic and
sell ads you got to come to me and say
what am i investing in you have to put
your thing into a container that's
investable nobody's writing a check to a
person yeah packaging and then and then
it gets hard because once you package it
you have to be able to explain it in
business terms and that's not
necessarily what everybody does this is
where it gets into partnerships one
thing I would tell you based on the
Bible and picking up if you and I both
grew up in Milwaukee you know I would
have been a great partner for you
because I could have been the
businessman to the art if that's how
you're thinking about it maybe you're
the business part but it's not what
you've been bringing up yet I don't know
if this rep has do you think both right
now yeah well look I mean you should you
should be putting out content on a very
regular basis you should start a pillar
show whether it's I mean vlogging I
think is very fascinating you know you
should be doing Instagram stories and
snapchat stories at scale you should be
putting out 7 to 25 pieces of content on
both those platforms a day
and let me explain how don't go fancy
document versus create when you when you
make you like that right it's a big it's
a big shift when I say 7 to 25 you say
my god how do I produce 7 to 25
meaningful things that will have me
respected versus document see that's
that's that's always the things like
refle that will get me respected after
like mm-hm anybody can put out [ __ ] you
know I don't want to put out [ __ ]
but [ __ ] a subjective my man and I got
good news for you you're fully in
control yeah
people was like Gary you put like my
mind control how many things I say no
they sent me quotes to put out an
Instagram nope I'm in control
who makes the final call in like
productions to produce her to direct I
don't know whoever who's the file person
great you're the producer my man Yeah
right I don't know you tell you take a
selfie with a nice skyline and yeah but
you got to put out stuff and you and you
got to fabricate it like when you're
like I still can't believe how many
people that live in New York
don't use New York people if I were you
and I had an hour right now go in the
[ __ ] Park right right now like I
don't know like go back to your
basketball roots stand outside the
garden right there and be like what do
you thing about the Knicks upcoming
season yeah interview four people one
person gets into a thoughtful
conversation he was the forum ball boy
in 1957 it's a nice story and boom you
see where I'm going people aren't
starting they're just not making they're
thinking they're pondering they're
strategizing they're debating the
difference between people like me and
and the far majority is I'm just doing
at all times I'm doing so much that I've
decided have a [ __ ] man walk around
with a camera and follow me cuz who
knows when it's gonna happen
and you know what's so funny in parallel
my brain right now we're gonna leave
here I'm gonna say to him
d-roc I want this whole thing cut the
whole thing like what I'm giving you so
many Neeb right now so I'm like [ __ ] it
let's just put it out right so I
or you know you have to be good enough
console all the time I personally go
through these periods like extreme
creativity and extreme just chill how do
you motivate yourself well how do you
continue this process in life go go go
go go and balance out like self-care and
checking in with yourself I do what
feels right to me you do it was right
dude yeah so if I got a check out for
the week I check out for the weekends
all time no creations people are like
where's your snapchats like I'm at home
gotta be with my family like I don't
punish myself but that's really hard for
me right now
good of course oh that's anything if I
do you nothing check you got enough you
had about doin [ __ ] I agree see where
I'm goin yeah matter of life I I don't
think you should I don't I don't think
you should squander it but like I mean
like you just gotta you know listen this
is back to do you know yourself or do
you aspire to be something you might
actually not be this is the toughest
question of it all my man I mean if you
want to be respected and really known
show the [ __ ] up are you [ __ ] kidding
me with a week going a week without
doing something you know I don't know
how much into my content you are but I
always say nobody you've ever met got
there without the hard work nobody you
know it's just real you know do you know
how insane dailyvee and the snapchat
stories has been to everybody they
didn't realize how hard I was going at
it you can't believe how many you can't
believe how many people's you know many
[ __ ] people used to say the word luck
that that word luck has gone right back
like nobody has the audacity say that to
my face now and I love it and that's why
I did it I did it I made it for you
because you can watch it be like okay
but I think yours is different I think a
lot of theirs is different it's because
I'm not fancy about it document over
create
I mean there's so much magic going on it
dude you're [ __ ] New York City you
know you people again I'm gonna cut this
whole thing because device every been
using any of them sitting in a place
that's not New York City you got a
billion [ __ ] stories out there
you don't feel motivated that you need
to tell a story today or create oh let
somebody else to do it you have so much
charisma walk near two seconds you
walked in here in two seconds and I'm
like okay this kid's got a little meth
like you can rule up on anybody and get
them feel comfortable yeah except
racists that's it's like a dancer but do
you I mean yeah
that's so [ __ ] awesome so you can't
create distribute got it you can't
create today
that's a facilitator you know yeah man
yeah there's no excuse for not talking
to the world it just doesn't have to be
your thoughts and words every time yeah
I'm on fire right now I'm on fire dear
Aki you have like minutes yeah let me
look I'm going until they pull me out
you're already 8 minutes over go you're
winning yeah don't even work don't even
think of you're not even close to that
well because you don't have the money to
like really build the team right you can
have homies help you out along the way
truth is I'm exhausted those resources
good let me let me give you a real good
answer I got a feel for you right now
you need to work on you before you worry
about a team what do you mean I mean you
got to get your [ __ ] together
like you're working you're responding to
the right thing like I don't know much
what what I do well is I talk and then
through reaction I listen that's how I
get a lot done in a meeting like this
right
I could tell that you you've got certain
things that you need to do before you
worry about a team get your thing in
place
this is either yeah I get great at what
we just talked about if I go look now
and I'm going to check now I'm curious
if I go look in a couple weeks and I'm
like oh my god
6/6 you know Instagram stories per day
like [ __ ] you know for Instagram post
like he's been on Twitter on point his
facebook so he's got a YouTube channel
now he's like create distribute you know
do all that stuff interview like
there's so much creative [ __ ] man like
like I'm way more creative than I
realized
because stuff comes so natural to me
like for example like do a meme and
that's just a slang term for it like go
take a picture on every odd Street in
New York in Manhattan like I don't know
like go start at 1:13 and then 111 and 1
oh not like anything could be like right
I call it odd corner and just literally
do an interview every day on Instagram
for a minute starting at 1 13th
all the way down that's cool right and
like that so I'm just making [ __ ] up
like I don't know like the odd corner
hashtag odd corners your show every
[ __ ] Monday you go to [ __ ] 113th
the next week 111 that literally you
stand there until somebody walks by and
you interview that person and that's the
[ __ ] show I think what I'm good at is
building a pillar up top that creates
content below dailyvee askgaryvee show
right and then all flows from there
where did this quote come from I don't
know
you know like somewhere along the way
that that's what's powerful and I think
you need to create I think one thing
that people struggle with is they need
they think they need to pick needs to
come from them and it needs to come from
the structure down instead of got it
and that's why you wake up you're like
damn I'm not feel like you know how hard
it is to manifest that kind of original
creative thing from the bottom but if
you if you may if you literally lived
your life under show think of yourself
as like CNN or MSNBC Monday's odd corner
sit like if you're white boarded now on
like many shows that you could do
Mondays odd corner Tuesdays like subway
shots Wednesday's like suburbs you're
just literally going out like you know
and all of a sudden suburbs cliques and
all of a sudden Toyota's hitting you up
and say hey we'll pay you and you'll
drive a Toyota to to Jersey
to Long Island so I'm going but you got
to put yourself in that position but
what you then are able to do is you
don't have to think you know why
podcasts have worked for a lot of people
because they interview people
so they don't have to do the work that's
right that's why when everybody's like
oh I love this podcast I'll Gary Vee and
I'm like you don't get it
they're just interviewing people I'm
creating original from the get my
version of that was what's a better
version of that Oh answer people's
questions also scalable but brings value
to those individuals and the entire
community so got it good man give me an
update in 30 days I mean I'm dead
serious
this is you know you came in here and
said I'd like to start to process a
relationship ideas are [ __ ] executions
the games right email me in 32 either
you're gonna email me in 30 days and say
look what I did or what you're gonna do
is not email me but you got a brother
who says thank you for those that have
gone through this video I would really
love a detailed comment on the number
one takeaway from this video this is
there something here that I really want
to continue to expand on that I think is
going to really bring value and help
people that are in a rut really win so
please in depth comment on the one thing
that you really took away from this
video